وحش روسيه في سماء اوكرانيا نتحدث هنا عن
صاروخ كروز كي اتش 1 2 الذي عجزت اوكرانيا
عن التصدي له لانها لا تملك اي اسلحه او
دفاعات جويه قادره على اسقاطه كما تقول
هذا الصاروخ اطلقته القوات الروسيه في
هجمتها الاخيره على مدينه نيبرو على من
خمسه قاذفات بعيده المدى من طراز تيو توني
تو ام ثري وتم تنفيذ عمليات الاطلاق من
منصه ومن منطقه كورس ومن مياه بحراسه
صاروخ كروز من طراز كي اتش ون تو يعتبر
احد اقوى الصواريخ التي تمتلكها روسيا
يبلغ وزنه نحو 950 كلغراما ويصل مداه الى
نحو 6 كيلو متر بدا تطوير هذا الصاروخ
مشاهدينا عام
1958 بهدف تدمير حاملات الطائرات تركيا
ومجموعات حاملات الطائرات القتاليه ان ذلك
ويمكن حمل واطلاق الصاروخ عبر قذفات
متوسطه المدى ويستخدم هذا الصاروخ ويستخدم
ايضا الوقود السائل الذي تصل سرعته الى
524 كيلو متر بالساعه روسيا قامت في عام
وفي تحويل ترسمتها من هذا الصاروخ الى
التخزين قبل ان تعيد استخدامه مع بدايه
عملياتها العسكريه في اوكرانيا التي بدات
في فبراير الماضيه